no one grows up thinking I want to be a
great non-alcoholic beer producer not
alcoholic beer had never really crossed
my mind as any sort of thing that would
be a big part of my life prior to being
in the business of non-alcoholic beer
itself
[Music]
My Lifestyle was an intense one I've
never been someone to go slow at
anything I do but it was wake up early
work out very intense day job in the
financial world and one of the most
intellectually challenging environments
there is at 0.72 and then go out to work
dinners really burning the candles at
both ends and wake up and do it again
the next day it was everything about
high performance and my workouts my job
and everything I did
foreign
[Music]
I grew up as most people did with all
the jokes around the existing category
and why would you drink it kind of the
decaf coffee jokes and it wasn't until I
was living this high performance Modern
Life that it occurred to me beer and
adult beverages in general have not
adapted to the modern lifestyle and
there was an enormous Gap here about
only 50 percent of adults consume
alcohol on a regular basis and the
breadth of non-alcook options and on and
off-premise places for high performing
adults was super limited and that struck
me and once the wheel started turning I
couldn't turn it off because I was
drinking five or six nights a week not
in huge amounts most of the time I
assumed everyone drank with regularity
every time they went out to a bar or
restaurant anything and it took me
stepping away from drinking for
performance lifestyle reasons to realize
that not that many people actually
consume a lot of alcohol with regularity
it's actually a very small percentage of
population that consumes a majority of
the alcohol so as I was in these places
bars and restaurants and in pain looking
for better options I realized that there
were a lot of people like me and it
didn't start out as I was researching a
business idea and I didn't necessarily
know I was going to do this but it
became a passion that I just couldn't
turn off before I knew it I was working
on it nights and weekends waking up at
four in the morning before I went to
work I found myself in a spreadsheet
working on the business plan on Saturday
when it wasn't even my full-time job and
that's kind of when I knew that this was
something I was really passionate about
for the first time in my life
I expected when I started talking about
non-alcoholic beer all my friends family
and colleagues would think I was
absolutely insane and they were all like
yeah if it tasted good I would probably
drink that a good amount and like that's
when I was like whoa like if there were
better options I think almost everyone
would drink a great non-alcoholic option
with some regularity and then I started
running actual surveys and got big data
behind that
the not alcoholic beer market in 2016
and 17 was 0.3 percent of the overall
Beer Market in the U.S but as I read in
surveys of thousands of people 55 plus
would say they would drink great
non-alcoholic beer with regularity if it
didn't come with the bad taste and the
stigmas attached to it but then when you
talk to people in the industry everyone
would very nicely say hey like be really
careful how much you invest here there's
no demand for us there's no evidence
that this is going to be a thing and I
think it just wasn't a thing because
there wasn't great options that got
people excited
[Music]
I teamed up with an incredible
co-founder of brewmaster and John and he
was by far the most talented person who
had ever turned his attention on this
category before John had won every
alcoholic craft beer award Under the Sun
and we started Brewing at super small
scale on Gatorade jugs just making
tweaks dialing in that process and
getting the real award-winning craft
beer that just happened to be
non-alcoholic the first batches were
kind of fun and kind of terrifying I had
been brewing for seven years at that
time but we really had to deconstruct
Brewing as it was and think about the
ingredients in a much different way and
so it was the first time I had
experienced those same ingredients in a
different format and so it was a great
learning process for me as a brewer so
really I was starting from scratch it
really started with the product at a
super small scale hundreds of Trials and
then the same kind of Grassroots
attention out in the world we went door
to door taste testing retailers meeting
people at Finish Lines or races when
they were sweaty and having a good time
putting a non-alcoholic beer in their
hand and telling them a little bit about
it I think we created thousands and
thousands of super fans face to face
that for summer and then we just have
kept doing that building our community
authentically talking to people getting
people excited along the whole way
the biggest difference between Brewing
traditional and non-alcoholic beer is
food safety primarily because you don't
have ethanol as a preservative and we
want to create a shelf-stable product
that will be good for six months or a
year and in order to do that without a
preservative you have to be really
careful about your entire process
through and through until it's a
finished product in a can and
pasteurized what makes us unique and not
unique at all at the same time is that
we don't ever remove the alcohol so we
don't require that single unit that
single machine that strips everything
out we brew a beer that is fully
fermented to under 0.5 percent so we
don't have to add a step we don't have
to remove anything or add anything back
foreign
it's a real exciting time for athletic
as we take on Kirk Dr Pepper as a new
partner they let our series D with a
recent investment in that we're getting
a really scaled partner operates at the
biggest of the beverage industry and a
great advisor in our Corner building and
manufacturing business is expensive
we've built two of the biggest
non-alcoholic beer breweries in the
world in Connecticut and California and
that investment allows us to get those
facilities up and running profitably and
puts us on a really good sustainable
financial future for all of our
teammates
Bing commercial hasn't always been cool
in the beer industry but from John and
I's perspective there's nothing cooler
than providing great jobs great
opportunity for teammates and that comes
with financial stability especially in
this economy
one of the biggest learnings I found in
developing athletic and our Brewing
process was that it wasn't alcohol I was
after it was all the ingredients and if
we can just find a way to Showcase those
same ingredients in a different format
people are going to like it just the
same humans have been drinking beer for
5 000 years I would think it's got a
really important place in society and so
we wanted to give people options that
fit their life anywhere anytime no
matter what their preference is by
giving people the full social and taste
experience of drinking beer without the
alcohol it just allows us to take beer
where it's never gone before
[Music]
foreign